bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du programme du candidat qui a
été choisi pour représenter le parti
socialiste benoît hamon
[Musique]
son objectif est plutôt simple il
souhaite faire battre à nouveau le coeur
de la france et ça ça passe selon lui
par trois axes réalisé un progrès social
et écologique rendre la république
bienveillante et humaniste et que la
france soit indépendante et protectrice
démocratie benoît hamon souhaite la mise
en place d'une 6ème république
il souhaite remettre le citoyen au coeur
de l'état en instaurant la possibilité
d'un 49,3 citoyen en lui laissant décidé
de l'attribution d'une partie du budget
de l'état 5000 un max et on lui
accordant le pouvoir décrire la loi de
manière collaborative via des
amendements citoyens il souhaite aussi
globalement rénové l'appareil politique
français cela passe selon lui par une
réforme du sénat
une limitation du cumul des mandats dans
le temps la limitation d'un président la
république à un unique septennat elle
passe des quinquennats ou la
modernisation du conseil constitutionnel
pour que les anciens présidents de la
république ne s'y retrouvent pas par
défaut enfin et les peaux plus de
transparence pendant les élections et à
ce titre il souhaite que chaque candidat
publie la liste de ses donateurs de plus
de 2500 euros pour éviter les conflits
d'intérêts et veut par ailleurs
reconnaître le rôle du vote blanc en lui
permettant d'annuler une élection s'il
est majoritaire eko eko économie la
grosse réforme de benoît hamon c'est le
revenu universel d'existence pour
définir un nouveau rapport au travail
comment ça se passerait dès 2018 le rsa
serait à hauteur de 600 euros est versée
automatiquement à tous les ayants droit
avec à côté un revenu d'existence versée
à tous les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans pour
décider du reste montant financement
calendrier il souhaite une grande
conférence citoyenne pour fixer le
périmètre du revenu universel
ce revenu sera ensuite étendue à
l'ensemble de la population
l'idée c'est qu'à terme il atteindra la
somme de 750 euros
la seconde réforme dont on a beaucoup
entendu parler c'est la légalisation par
une distribution encadrées du cannabis
pour tuer les trafics à la source niveau
emploi ils s'opposent à ce qui peut
fragiliser la position du salarié il
veut donc abroger la loi travail mais
aussi fortifier le statut d indépendant
en luttant contre les entreprises
hubert ise qui font du salariat déguisé
et en créant un statut unique de l'actif
pour dépasser les distinctions salariés
indépendants pour que ces questions ne
se posent plus parce qu'ils considèrent
qu'en france les bénéfices ont trop
souvent du côté des dividendes et non
l'investissement
il souhaite moduler l'impôt sur les
sociétés en fonction de la
des bénéfices réinvestis dans
l'entreprise par ailleurs il propose la
mise en place d'une taxe robots dans les
entreprises remplaçant les travailleurs
par des machines puisque le bénéfice
créé bénéficie principalement aux
actionnaires et veut supprimer les
rémunérations des patrons
dépourvu de lien avec l'amélioration des
résultats de l'entreprise ils s'opposent
aussi farouchement à l'évasion fiscale
il veut mettre en place en compte rendu
public pays par pays pour toutes les
entreprises renforcer les moyens de
poursuivre des fraudeurs et adapter la
fiscalité française pour que de grands
groupes comme amazon n'échappe plus à
l'impôt il souhaite d'ailleurs refondre
l'impôt sur le revenu le rendre plus
progressif entre autres en augmentant le
nombre de tranches pour une meilleure
individualisation il envisage de
remplacer les sf et la taxe foncière par
un unique impôt sur le patrimoine et
pour la transition écologique ne
dépendent pas du marché et prévoit
d'instaurer une tva attractive pour les
produits à faible empreinte carbone et
de rendre la fiscalité incitative pour
guider l'épargné des français vers des
investissements verts écologie point
primordial de son programme benoît hamon
souhaite la mise en place d'un plan zéro
déchet pour le pays via la lutte contre
le gaspillage alimentaire en combat
contre l'obsolescence programmée et
l'obligation des métropoles de recycler
50% leurs déchets produits annuellement
à l'horizon 2022 et puisqu'on parle
d'objectif il souhaite l'utilisation de
50% d'énergies renouvelables par le pays
dès 2025 et la sortie du diesel d'ici à
2050 il va aussi sanctuariser les biens
communs air eau et sol pour les protéger
contre toute dégradation ou risque de
captation privé dans cette logique de
protection
il souhaite appliquer le principe de
précaution en interdisant les
perturbateurs endocriniens et les
pesticides dangereux
et plutôt que de continuer avec les
pesticides il propose d'investir pour
développer le bio et l'agro écologie
sociale il soit de la création d'un
nouveau service public
la brigade de lutte contre les
discriminations pour vérifier
régulièrement les pratiques des
structures publiques et privées en la
matière pour lutter contre les
inégalités hommes femmes et propose en
plus un renforcement des sanctions en
cas de non respect de l'égalité
salariale
l'extension la pma aux femmes seules et
aux couples homosexuels
l'augmentation du délai de prescription
du viol du nombre de centres de planning
familial ou l'extension du congé
paternité pour la santé outre la mise en
place d'un droit à la santé universel
il souhaite mettre en place le droit de
mourir dans la dignité pour les
personnes atteintes d'une maladie
incurable diplomatie à l'échelle
internationale benoît hamon souhaite
faciliter l'accueil des
j'ai via la création d'un visa
humanitaire pour ouvrir une voie d'accès
légal sécurisé mais temporaire au
territoire français aux personnes en
situation de détresse humanitaire et
l'élimination des obstacles à
l'intégration des demandeurs d'asile en
leur demandant une autorisation de
travailler après trois mois de présence
sur le territoire et un accès renforcé à
l'apprentissage de la langue française
vis-à-vis des accords internationaux de
libéralisme économique
benoît hamon suspendra si l'élu l'accord
de libre-échange avec le canada et beira
à ce que le taffetas ne voit pas le jour
au niveau européen et ne remet pas en
cause les traités mais souhaite négocier
avec les partenaires européens
l'annulation de la dette des pays du sud
de l'europe et l'harmonisation fiscale
entre pays par un rapprochement du taux
de l'impôt sur les sociétés un taux
plafond de tva et une coordination
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
l'idée par exemple de créer un nouvel
impôt européen sur les gaffes et les
multinationales pour augmenter le budget
de l'union européenne
j'espère que programme est maintenant
plus clair pour vous comme d'habitude
dans les sources le lien vers son
programme complet et comme d'habitude je
vous invite à le consulter
parce qu'on cinq minutes on passe
forcément à côté de certains points on
se retrouve très vite pour le prochain
candidat
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
merci à tous merci notamment au type
heures pour soutenir financièrement le
projet love peace tiens